so
uh thank you for your time first of all
today and uh thank you for joining me to
talk about all things
marvel's avengers kate bishop before we
get into why we get the chat today i
always like to start off with just a
kind of a wellness check
uh so how are you doing in this insane
year of 2020
um i think as well as can be expected
um yeah i mean it's been a wild one
i've i've been lucky in that um
uh the show that i'm on mythic quest on
apple tv plus uh we had a second season
and we were able to go back and film
yeah and and now i'm back home and i can
do work from home so i'm i'm definitely
very lucky very grateful
um and hopeful that we get out of this
soon
yeah same uh it's been a pretty busy
year for you too just you know just
scrolling down the old imdb page or
the headlines that keep popping up with
your name and for different kind of
major roles and major titles that pop up
and i want to get to those uh in a few
minutes but
first of all how did the opportunity
originally come up to play kate bishop
i just auditioned for it i i got an
audition for kate
and um it was a really funny script
she's doing like a stakeout mission with
clint basically it was all i think it
was
all code names and um and that kind of
thing
but um yeah it was really fun scene and
um i had a lot of fun with her and
um i had the instinct during the
audition to do the whole thing
eating trail mix like she just didn't
give a [ __ ] and she was like
not worried about getting caught and
that kind of stuff and so
kind of from the word go uh i i felt
like i
i had keyed into something kind of fun
with her and um the crystal dynamics
folks agreed and
and they cast me very cool yeah a lot of
the kind of
quirky i think is a good maybe way to
describe her she's definitely unique
she's got her own kind of approach to
the world and your
voice and your performance comes through
beautifully to bring that character to
life
what were maybe some of the notes like
that uh did you go back and forth with
the the cd team to say
to kind of shape the character or figure
out what it was they wanted or was it
just
trail mix and it was good to go from
there it was kind of just trail mix i
mean i mean
i i did a few different options in the
audition
and then um when we when we just
basically sat down to actually record
um we did a few lines we tried a couple
of things and they seemed really happy
with
with the stuff that i was bringing and
then we kind of were just off to the
races
um and what was really fun about the
recording process was that i
i did have room to play they let me
improv and try things and add stuff and
take away stuff and
um i really felt like i was able to make
kate my own which was really fun
um so yeah it was it was really
fun just sort of a joyful experience um
they're really great to work with
and i had a great director kell and um
yeah it was just a blast the whole thing
i'm sorry as soon as you said your your
director was cal l i just my brain i
know
i know i'm sure he gets that a lot i'm
sure
just just to clarify i think you've done
uh mocap and facial performance capture
work before correct me if i'm wrong
did you was that also the case for kate
or was it voice performance only what
was the
what was the process therapy um i think
i came into
production maybe a little bit later so
there was some performance capture that
had already been done
for her so i was just voice but um but
yeah it was still
um i still felt like i had a lot of
ownership over her and uh i had a lot of
room to play which was great
you mean to tell me that wasn't you
doing back flips and teleporting all
over the place
on screen i know it's hard to believe
but uh i know is it breaking your
immersion
a little bit uh speaking of so so the
dlc just dropped recently i had a chance
to play through it with uh with my chat
on stream
i had a question for you um since the
the planned dlc kind of it was it was
planned to come out after the game's
release
they were just wondering about how long
ago did you actually do your uh recorded
lines
for this particular dlc oh man
time doesn't mean anything to me anymore
um it's hard to remember i mean
i was allowed to go out in the world um
if that's any indication i believe i
mean some of it was last year there was
a bit of it this year i'm pretty sure
um yeah because of i'm remembering the
studio i was in so yeah i think some of
it was
um end of year last year beginning of
this year and then sprinkling
during the last nine months okay finish
things out that'll make chat happy
um speaking of being in studio and
speaking of the the fantastic voice cast
that's kind of already in place for the
the core cast
did you have to record most of uh most
of your lines by yourself or did you get
a chance to actually interact with the
rest of your cast mates
i recorded most of it by myself um it is
it is really nice though to know who is
cast in the different roles because
even just knowing the actor can kind of
bring something like if i know i'm
talking to laura
or i know i'm talking to travis it can
kind of change things a little bit
so um their spirits were present even
though i wasn't able
to talk to them directly it's funny with
all the names
for the cast and yours obviously
included big names folks who know video
games who know who know tv
who know animation they they know your
name so it's sort of like those
the strengths of your voice performances
definitely come through to the character
you already talked a little bit about
kind of making kate your own but
what was it about the character of kate
bishop that stood out to you personally
well i've always really liked kate a lot
from the comics i mean
she's she's really really funny and i
think that's
that was honestly the the main initial
draw is that
um there's a sort of naturalistic
quality to her
and a really great sense of humor and
that kind of thing is really fun to play
especially in video games you know um i
think
video games are constantly progressing
and telling more complex and intricate
narratives and
it's i in my experience a relatively
rarer thing to have characters that also
inject a lot of humor in
to the narrative so um so that's always
exciting when there's a
funny character that's up in a video
game that and getting to play her was
so great definitely yeah i love the kind
of personality that comes through she's
kind of she's her own person but she's
kind of this mix of this kind of
a youthful energy and optimism that
kamala brings to the team but she's also
got she can go toe toe with uh tony
uh for wit and sharpness and and just
the back and forth which i absolutely
loved
uh there's a bit more depth to kate in
this in this story we don't get to to
learn too much about her but we learn
more about her relationship with
the other hawkeye clint barton uh is
there anything you can talk about as far
as
maybe the acting back and forth with
that i know you did it solo but
is there anything you talk about maybe
the relationship between the two
hawkeyes that we introduced to
yeah i think what's kind of cool about
um the storyline for kate is
you know even though she is sort of wise
cracking and badass and all that kind of
stuff
she has an emotional through line in the
story which is that she has a sort of
sense of abandonment from the events of
a day
and she was so close to becoming an
avenger
and now there's just sort of the sense
of rejection and a kind of
a desire almost to keep them at arm's
length to sort of believe she can do it
by herself
um and i think you know
i really love her sense of loyalty to
clint
and that genuine affection you know
there's nothing romantic about it they
just are
he's a mentor but also she can kind of
she can poke fun at him in the way that
only like almost like a younger sister
can
do and so they have that sort of
familial bond and i think that's part of
why
finding him is so important to her
because she doesn't really have a sense
of family
outside of him at the beginning so um
i think they do i think i think they
have a really nice
there's a sweetness to them and a
sweetness to their connection and their
bond and she has a lot of loyalty to him
um which i think is really endearing
yeah and it's a great part of the arc
that plays through
and we'll touch on this more in a minute
because that story's not quite done so
we have a little bit more to talk about
uh in the future months ahead but
you mentioned being a fan of of cape
from the comics so when you were
auditioning for the role or when you
just saw it come across
the boards what was your initial
reaction be like oh
kate bishop this is a character we don't
usually get to see so
you know what stories maybe flashed
through your mind or was it just kind of
like i just have to go for this
i just i just felt like i i was just
really excited to go for it i mean
um there's this one panel that i always
imagine
um of kate that i know that my brother
loves that i think she sees
i think she sees under deadpool's mask
and the panel is just her going
like just freaking out silently to
someone
acting really cool to him and then
turning around and being like like to
someone else
and that sort of thing is i i love that
about her
um there's just something so human to
her and and
so funny and so grounded and so when i
when i found out that it was kate i got
really really excited because i i do
think that she is
she's well known but not as well known
as other marvel characters and i think
she brings such a
fun flavor to the cast
especially um especially you know
amongst the female cast you know you
have i think she's a different energy
and a different quality to like
kamala or to natasha um
that i think really rounds out um the
women in the cast as well in a really
cool way
so um yeah i was i was really excited
when i found out it was kate
uh speaking of uh female marvel comic
superheroes i'm i'm waiting to be able
to run an all-female team in this game
we're not quite there
uh with kate hopefully soon who would
you maybe like to see in the future
is there and this can be any marvel
superhero
because marvel's avengers kind of has an
open book they can kind of pull whoever
they want who would you personally like
to fan cast
as the next character i mean
there is a part of me that would love to
see uh lawyer she-hulk
sure that'd be a great component to hulk
too it'd be nice to see somebody else
kind of go to go toe-to-toe with the
the strength uh be nice uh did you have
a chance to actually play through as
your character is that something you do
with your characters in video games are
you much of a gamer i am i am a gamer i
haven't been able to um
play as kate yet because it just came
out yesterday but um but yes
i i do like to uh i do like to play the
games i'm in
i know that sometimes it i've spoken to
people that don't like to do that
it's just too weird for them um it's
definitely also weird for me but i also
find it to be a learning experience i
think
it's actually it's sort of interesting
to review your work
i think if it doesn't give you a heart
attack to um
to sort of reflect and learn on okay
um i feel like this scene really worked
this one i would have done this
differently
can i remember you know back to when i
recorded that in the booth
what was going on that day um what are
some tools i can use in the future to
sort of help massage this kind of thing
like
it helps me give myself a performance
review kind of
um and then also i'm i'm really
fortunate that
basically all the games that i've been
in are really fun so
they're just fun to play yeah no she's
super fun uh
once you kind of got a handle on the
character and how she kind of moved how
she how her combat worked
super fun to play uh it's a fun game to
begin with i really have a blast playing
it it's been one of my like daily games
since launch
um and this is a new kind of like fresh
uh injection of fun
have you checked out any of her
cosmetics any of her costumes any of her
her various looks uh have you had a
chance to look at those
i have i have seen some of the cosmetics
and they're great
they're pretty wild yeah some of them
are pretty wild uh before i run out of
time with you i want to get into maybe a
look ahead a little bit so
this first dlc it introduced kate to a
lot of players around the world in the
game
and now people get to add her to their
roster part of the team but we know
there's a second dlc that's on the way
and we are assuming
uh that kate's gonna be pretty featured
in that too so what can you tease about
operation hawkeye future imperfect
i really don't want to give any spoilers
tricky one um
i can say that kate is featured okay
it'd be kind of weird for there to be a
hawk idea
dlc and her not to be in it probably
yeah we can check that box just to make
sure yeah um
but uh yeah i don't want to spoil
anything about the story but it is
it's a fun one i think people are
especially hawkeye fans are really gonna
like it i think
fair enough um and as i mentioned
earlier you've had a pretty busy year so
far you know not just this game but
quite a few other games tv series
animation and more so
maybe kind of a little more of a
reflective question for you personally
but
what are you maybe most grateful for as
you look back on the crazy year that was
uh 2020 what's what's something that
sticks out that you're like
really proud of or really grateful for
in this year
um well i'm i'm grateful to be working
at all
i know that there's a lot of people in a
lot of industries that
weren't able to make the move to working
from home i'm really lucky that
um voice acting you know it was impacted
of course
but um folks have found really
innovative workarounds i mean
i have a uh a
head cam in this booth behind me to work
on
horizon forbidden west they just they
said i have all this gear
to you know so that i can do performance
capture from home
um which is really amazing
um because i know a lot of people don't
have that
right now and um more than anything i
also i mean
it's the it's the obvious answer but i'm
really grateful for
the community that i have the the
friends that i have in my life
and um it's
you can't really get this kind of thing
alone so um
and and also you know games have been a
way for me to stay connected to friends
they've been a way for me to um
turn off the real world for a little bit
i mean i think
i think games people have used games for
that reason
for since time immemorial but i think in
this year particularly
games were really important for folks
and um so i i am grateful to be in an
industry that's
honestly i think it's i think it's
helping people during this time
thank you so much a great answer and and
thank you for answering uh
earnestly when i put you on the spot
there to kind of i don't know look back
on the entirety of 2020
in the last moments my last question for
you today before i have to let you go
what is up next
for you either in the remaining days of
this year that maybe you have a project
coming out in the last few weeks
or some maybe highly anticipated titles
coming out in 2021
so um mythicquest season two
is um almost done filming so that's
going to come out at some point i'm not
sure when but i'm i'm hoping it's i
would assume it's next year
um and we are really really excited
about this season there's really awesome
stuff in it uh and i hope people check
it out
and then of course um horizon forbidden
west
i'm so excited for people to play that
and um
i actually don't know what the release
date on uh the ghost of molly mcgee is
but
um it is coming out
soon ish i think so keep an eye out for
that
um yeah i think those are the
i think those are the biggens that's
good i'm sure horizon is going to keep
everybody
very busy uh for quite some time myself
included i'm very much looking forward
to that
great but uh uh thank you again so much
for your time today and uh wish you the
best of luck with the role of the dlc
all the other projects that you have
coming up and happy holidays to you and
yours so thanks again
same thank you thanks